le wipeout de l'irsst et paris saclay
c'est une tournée d'entrée on est depuis
le 23 août
on va à la rencontre des étudiants et
des équipes sur le terrain donc dans
l'ensemble des établissements d'univers
t paris saclay on va présenter
l'université les opportunités qui sont
offertes aux étudiants
on va aussi leur présenter des
événements en rapport avec leur
formation et on fait ça jusqu'au 26
novembre
voilà on s'est vraiment une tournée dans
l'ensemble des établissements on
s'inscrit c'est tellement s'inscrit dans
différentes configurations par exemple
aujourd'hui on est sur un événement qui
est un stand l'association donc là on
sort d'un script notre stand
après yad autres événements où on est
par exemple comme ce soir à centrale
supélec où on va il course caritative
entrez votre stand no future un type en
restant d'une petite camionnette pleurs
universités qui sont elles en fonction
derrière et on a la documentation sp
sont des étudiants on va les voir où ils
viennent nous voir
voilà et on a des échanges avec le bon
sens et sciences ont tous au courant de
ce débat et saclay pour différentes
raisons donc s'est aussi inscrit sur les
faces de la carte étudiante
certains sont là depuis plusieurs années
donc ils font vieux projet se mettre en
place
alors après le niveau d'information à
ses différents longs on est là aussi
pour justement les sensibiliser
davantage renforcer l'information quand
ils en ont déjà
et en fonction de leur niveau
d'information par exemple pour ceux qui
s'intéressent au masters leur présentait
plus précisément notre offre de manière
mutualisée
jusqu'ici opération est un franc succès
on a fait quasiment une trentaine de
dates du ski si on a touché plus de
mille étudiants
lorsqu'un bon score les finançons rallye
nous voir ils sont contents qu'on vienne
chez eux leur apporter de l'information
il ya des petites animations aussi comme
un photocall où ils repartent avec une
photo voilà donc ils sont ravis ils ont
des petits cadeaux et ce premier
l'information pour qui c'est la passe
très bien